alors depuis tard qu'on dit que manger
bio c'est bon pour la santé
oui matthieu brasse bonsoir il ya une
nouvelle étude qui montre une étude
assez large d'ailleurs qui montrent que
les gens qui mangent bio ont moins de
risque de développer un cancer
oui oui les chiffres vous allez voir
sont quand même assez assez éloquent
c'est une étude qui a été publié une
étude française publiée aujourd'hui dans
un journal américain le german internal
medicine
ah c'est pas parce que ça a concerné
70000 personnes sur une période
d'environ sept ans entre 2009 et 2016 et
donc on l'a divisé les personnes en
quatre groupes qui ne mangeaient pas ou
peu bio jusqu'à à plus de 50% du bol
alimentaire qui provenaient de
l'agriculture biologique et en général
on a trouvé 25 % de risque de moins de
développer un cancer et dont certains
types de cancers cancer du sein chez les
femmes ménopausées -34% de risque le
lymphome qui est un type de cancer du
sang - 76% alors les auteurs de cette
étude assure qu'ils se sont efforcé au
maximum d'isoler le facteur agriculture
biologique parce que eux leur hypothèse
c'est de dire que ça provient des
pesticides parce que les pesticides on
les retrouve plus dans l'agriculture
conventionnelle et que dans les aliments
produits par l'agriculture biologique il
n'y en a pas et donc il faisait
l'hypothèse que les pesticides
pourraient être responsables de cancers
on peut écouter une des co-auteurs les
aliments les plus importants sont bien
sûr les aliments végétaux pour lesquels
il ya des résidus de pesticides avec les
produits animaux la dynamique est un
petit peu différente on s'est plutôt des
résidus d'antibiotiques etc ou des
principes de bioaccumulation et c'est
vraiment sur les produits végétaux qu'il
faut se concentrer pour réduire
l'exposition aux pesticides
alors j'ai atteint les gens à la maison
mathieu croizet ben oui mais les jeunes
gens qui mangent bio ils font plus de
sport
ils font donc très attention à
l'alimentation
il dort mieux etc c'est difficile
d'isoler le facteur bio quand même j'ai
parlé effectivement à 2
deux ans colloque spécialiste du change
du cancer du sein à montréal le docteur
boganim occulte hume dr robidoux au chum
ils disent oui c'était intéressant mais
il ya beaucoup de billets c'est
impossible d'isoler complètement oui ces
gens là qui consomment bio ont des
facteurs qui les protège de ce genre de
ce type de cancer mais par contre
l'hypothèse formulée par par les
chercheurs ici ils disent qu'elle est
intéressante parce que elle tend à
démontrer que oui de saines habitudes de
vie évidemment ça va dans le bon sens
certainement mais que surtout il faut au
maximum
bannir du régime alimentaire tout ce qui
est aliments transformés et ça
évidemment ce genre d'étude lavanant bon
sens parce que manger bio ça veut dire
qu'on consomme beaucoup moins d'aliments
qui sont sur les tablettes des épiceries
qui sont multi multi transformer voilà
ça va dans le bon sens comme vous dites
merci beaucoup monsieur